you know it's a very slow process we got
the galleys Steven sent us the galleys
which were at the time before the book
was printed like three inches thick and
it seemed like you know this would be
pretty neat but it may not happen most
films don't happen Steven they kind of
do and I should have realized that but
then you know we started it and had no
idea that it was gonna evolve into this
computer graphic show because we got the
galleys I think we hadn't even done t2
yet well I just come off of Robocop 2
which tanked and was a big stop-motion
show so I was like kind of burned out
and I got a call from Cathy who said
that hey we're gonna work we want to
make a dinosaur movie doesn't it sound
like fun it was like no it does not
sound like fun yeah should we have some
interesting I I don't know if you guys
remember this I mean that first
telephone call
she said Stephen wants to do it with
full robotic dinosaurs and it was like
you got to be kidding you couldn't do
that you know it was like no I mean you
know you can't do that Kathy and it was
like why well for the same reason
there's no golf courses on the moon I
mean we just can't do it
Janet her shinsen and James Jenkins had
brought me in and filmed me and sent the
tape to Stephen and then Stephen called
me in to meet me and talked to me and he
said I'm thinking about casting you as
Donald Gennaro I do want to let you know
how you're gonna die
and I thought wait a minute Donald
Gennaro lives he survives he in fact he
saves the children from the Raptor cave
and he said no he's gonna die on the
toilet and the state Tyrannosaurus Rex
is gonna eat him and I said to myself of
course if it was the other Donald
Gennaro they would have got a big star
to play that role so yeah that sounds
like a terrific way of having Donald
Gennaro meet his maker one of the great
things was to see a real dinosaur
created on the stage at that time by
Stan and Michael and Tre who are not
here I think should be acknowledged
because it was a big part of what that
t-rex was it came to life for everybody
at the times and at that time the
technology that was available for us was
a process that we'd come up with it at
ILM called go motion which is
essentially a computerized rod puppet
and so I think dennis is intention at
that point in time was to do a combo
between that and ispeed puppets is it
not man plus all the full-size robotics
cuz leftover was Stephens dream that he
could get these things for real and
these only effects as little as possible
and that's where Stan Winston's shop
came in and Stan crazy enough agreed to
build these full-sized characters you
know and his abilities he really did
just jump in where no one else would
have in their right mind especially
given the level of work he'd already
done and to take that on at that time
the way he did I mean he he was just a
master at inspiration and making you
feel like things that really shouldn't
be able to be done could be done and and
also Stephen had said they're only just
be light misty rain until the first shot
and then he started just pouring on the
rain so all the foam kept getting wetter
their gigantic robotic sponges yeah
that's why he's trying to say once you
get you get soaked and you cut they have
to change my shirt and wipe me down but
they also had to take towels and wipe
down
the t-rex because like you said he would
just like hers and what computers are
good at of course is replicating and you
can take a working a paste at a thousand
times so it seemed like if there was
something with a lot of animals in it it
would be you know in the distance we
could maybe make that look real enough
so it looked like it had skin and was a
real living animal not a plastic CG
thing which is with you or chrome like
we haven't e to or so we could see
nickel that time so I proposed that to
Steven and he said you know we've got a
sequence in the in this film with this
attack of Gallimimus is perfect so we
started doing tests on that at the same
time that was going on Steve Williams a
mark to pay in the back of ILM we're
working on trying to do with t-rex which
I didn't think we were ready for at all
but privately he was sort of putting one
together and we did our Gallimimus test
the thing looked great you know that's
moving ahead we can get that in the film
we're doing CG and then the t-rex worked
also a lot of it was was blue screen I
guess and so a lot of the close-ups you
have to do what an actor has to do which
is use your imagination but once you saw
the dinosaur and you saw them move you
go that's so real that I can it's not
going to be hard to use that as
imagination we were in bloody you know
paradise when before the hurricane hit
and afterwards it looked like these
giants had just taken a weed whacker and
we'd whacked the entire island it was it
was devastated there's a Kathy Kennedy
story I just want to say because it
relates to this which is about producing
I was not there I'd left the day before
how fortunate for you exactly
and you know no one could get on and off
that Island cuz it was a military zone
and so she went to the the head
commander and she said what if I pay a
hundred thousand dollars for medicine
and food to come fly in and then when
you've offloaded it I put my crew back
on and get out so that's how she got
everybody out
that's why if she ever runs for
president you should vote for a film
crew is a is an entity and two unto
itself and they just they went to work
they just with electric saws and stuff
like that just cleared all that stuff
away so vehicles could get into the to
the hotel and basically down there we
felt very safe in that ballroom because
they did have food and generators and
and liquor and they took care of us they
took care of us and we really even with
the chandelier shaking and the whole and
Steven was going I'm thinking about
going out the back door when we get in
the middle of the eye of the hurricane
so we can film some stuff and I went
that sounds great mm-hmm and of course
my wife says you stay here with your
sons you're not going out I went you're
probably right
mark Ruggiano from DreamWorks called and
said Steven wants to dimensionalize
Jurassic and said what's the first step
said well we have to watch the movie
with them and you know as you say that
out loud you're like wait a second
that's going to end up happening and
then you have me and a couple people
that work with me for the first meeting
we go we sit in the ambling theater with
mark early on oh and Steven Spielberg
and we watched Jurassic on silent and we
just talked through the movie and had
what he wants the experience to be in
stereo
you have the t-rex attack scene which
for what we do is my personal nightmare
because you have practical rain in the
foreground you have a side window of a
car with reflection of the rain you then
have the kids in the car you then have
the driver side side mirror side window
you then have mid ground rain behind
that you then have the wires of the
paddock from the t-rex then you have all
of the foliage during a storm moving
around and then you have the t-rex show
and the shots like 1,500 frames and it
doesn't end and so for us we have to
assign depth to all of those elements
and at the same time the thing we were
most worried about which is can be
problematic and conversion is scale when
you need to mention high something and
to make sure the dinosaur doesn't lose
its you know the t-rex still feels as
big as it is what these guys created
when the girl was hanging down there and
and she gets pulled back up and the
Raptor leaps up in the camera I very
clearly was working with Erik Armstrong
on the animation on that saying no it
doesn't look 3d enough never dreaming in
a million years we were actually going
to convert it to 3d but but you could
tell there was a point when the
combination of the lens and the distance
in the performance gave you a 3d feeling
even in 2d and I haven't seen this yet
I'm looking forward tonight to sing
especially that's we got it there for
you great